real saint louis
goat legend you know because without you
it wouldn't be me
so um you don't get enough credit but
i'm always giving you the credit
uh
and you know you got to relax man you
got chill
you know you you might be able to tell
you all these videos you cussing out the
kids
you gotta chill but um
no
my big brother man appreciate you you
know it's all love you know i'm gonna
see you
this summer
oh what's it like hearing him just talk
about the impact that you have had on
him and his life and career
it's uh it's surreal in a lot of ways um
let's do oh yeah you're like getting
emotional yeah a little bit
uh cause
for me i didn't have that
that image per se like to me my older
brother was my favorite player outside
of you know the goats and the left as we
see on the court in the nba
so i didn't have that image of what a
pro is like you know
what recruiting was like you know going
through that phase like i seen it within
my family and so that was my way of
learning you know on the fly and so it's
funny that he talks about my aau team
because
he was a part of that it was way before
i called him brad bill elite years later
um but i used to yell at him and chew
him out the same exact way
but that speaks volumes you know that
just speaks volumes of his character
and
just who he is